we've got a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p here is a question about who would
I support if Bernie fails in the Democratic
primary.
Take a listen to this.
Hi David.
Um, so right now, uh, Bernie's kinda starting
to drop in the, in the polls.
So I know you're a big Bernie supporter.
If you were to go down, who would you start
to support?
Would it be Kamala Harris?
Would it be, um, Biden?
I don't think it would be.
Um, let me know your thoughts.
Thank you.
Robert White.
So listen, it is, I covered earlier in the
show that Bernie Sanders is no longer in second
place.
Elizabeth Warren, at least in the polling
of the last week, has surpassed Bernie and
Camila Harris and is now in second place.
So I, I of all, I haven't endorsed Bernie.
I've said the people I like the most are Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren.
I think Andrew Yang has some interesting ideas,
although I disagree with the implementation
about many of them.
I'm not a Biden Guy, I'm not a comma guy.
So, uh, ultimately if by the time Massachusetts
Votes Bernie is out, I would probably support
Elizabeth Warren on policy.
Now I know a lot of people say, listen, you're,
you're supporting someone who was a republican
for much of her life, uh, on policy.
Now she has most of the right ideas.
She can go deep on policy.
Uh, and though that Bernie and Warren are
still the top too, but I, I would not, uh,
W it's too early to really be having this
conversation.
We've just got to let it play out.
We haven't even had the second debate, which
is coming up in a couple of weeks.
So that would be my sense.
But if in the end, uh, when it comes time
for Massachusetts to vote, I vote in Boston.
Um, Warren is in and Bernie is out.
I'm probably going for Elizabeth Warren.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We'll talk about this.
Um, a new movement to storm area 51.
We will talk about New Zealand starting their
gun buy back program.
And we will talk about the governor of Tennessee
signing a proclamation, honoring some, uh,
an early KKK leader,
which has understandably, sparked a lot of
backlash.
All of those stories and more on today's bones.
Yeah.
The David Pakman show